you've never seen this meme where like
dudes in general men think that they
could land a plane what yeah it's like
like women will ask their boyfriends or
their husbands or whatever and be like
do you think if some if like the pilot
died and they called upon you to land
the plane you could do it and every
guy's like yeah I think that [__] do you
think like a 747 yeah [__] no you don't
think so no bro those things [__] fly
themselves dude you just gotta pop on
the headphones listen to their
instructions and you'd be good
don't think so
have you seen one of those like clusters
no like the instrument cluster at one of
those yeah I mean I'm sure I have seen a
picture of it or whatever but yeah I'm
just pull up a 747 instrument cluster
yeah that's not that much [__] dude
I'm sorry
have you ever seen
a drum set yeah I figured that [__] out
yeah
pull up a drum set
guys who make EDM have you ever have you
ever seen the Ableton interface yeah
guys have you yeah guys who make EDM and
have worked on cdjs walking up to the
747 instrument cluster during 9 11 be
like
the air traffic controller all right now
uh what you're going to want to do is
find the rear find the uh the rear
calipers and I'm like is that like the
EQ the mids what is that Tempo control
yeah speaking of planes crashing
hijack
oh is it good what is that I was it's
Idris elba's new shoes and it's good but
let me say this man pretty good I'm
getting pretty I'm getting pretty sick
of Apple TV dialogue yeah
two manicured I I didn't fully
understand what you meant by that
because when you said that
all I had really watched was like
Severance and Blackbird yep and
Blackbird was like Blackbird was like
that it was but I guess like it was easy
to miss because it was like based on
something real yeah but in these dramas
like Silo hijack
it's dude you can listen to these shows
like podcasts yeah they're so [__] on
the nose yeah they're like
the hijacker at the back of the plane
he's coming to the front oh my God is he
coming to the front he's coming to the
front he has a weapon but I'm DJing
right now yeah it's like smart premises
yeah with dialogue for dumb people yeah
it's [__] dude it's like fourth
grader dialogue yeah yeah so what's
hijacked about the blame it's just about
interesting in first class
[Laughter]
yeah
is he in the bathroom he's just in a
seat he's just trying to get it done in
his seat it's eight episodes of him
trying to [__] beat off
in every episode he like runs into a new
problem yeah the first one the flight
attendant kind of sees him yeah and he's
like yeah [__] yeah he's like
yeah exactly sir would you like it
no I'm fine thank you no I'm
I'll take water yeah damn it Germany
Vaseline
every episode it's like 24 every episode
is an hour yeah yeah 12 episode series
when will he come
yeah
yeah and obviously you know it does he
at the end in the 24th hour I think you
know he's gonna bust
no but then what's the series Arc
um maybe he falls in love on his way to
the bust
with with someone with someone yeah so
he's jacking off and looking at someone
and falling in love with them no no he
his initial is like he's he's just going
for pleasure yeah it's just a little bit
of lust like maybe he's like
yeah maybe like some he's watching
something and some like you know horny
scene comes on he's like oh [__] gotta
she's like I haven't busted in a long
time yeah he hasn't jacked off in 10
years okay since his his character's
wife died
hot 10 years ago and he's not had sex or
masturbated since he's heartbroken
but I like the stakes are high now yeah
yeah but then he sees a little you know
it watches a little sexy movie on the
plane yeah and this is him watching that
he's just seeing the scene right now
he's like yeah he thought his dick
stopped working and now it's firing up
on the plane and he checks the calendar
he's like well it's been 10 years yeah
that's probably long enough yeah you
know season one is just like trying to
wrestle with himself because he forgot
um what it's like to jack off right and
he can't quite get it right again
okay so for Eight Episodes a coming of
age if you will nice for Eight Episodes
he's trying to figure out how to jack
off again he's rediscovering his grip so
he has a boner for eight hours yeah his
first in-flight meal arrives like would
you like a drink and he's like
Diet Coke
in the can
I guess they can he's like gripping it
trying to just trying to just train his
arm again on episode eight
he's uh he's gripping a banana
and then
a lady from premium economy who stumbles
in
uh to use the restroom notices this odd
grip and she reaches over and she grabs
his hand and she's like let me help you
with that and he's like what
and she's helping him she's guiding his
hand she's like do you remember he's
like
and he goes like
he's like I remember
like remember some it's like it's a
montage of him in childhood College
he was thinking about his wife then and
then it comes back full circling is on
his wife he's like
he's like
he starts crying again
and it's like ding we've begun our
descent into Dubai yeah and that's
season one yeah and then season two
right and then season two what someone
tries to hijack the point and but he's
too busy jerking off no he's hard and he
wants to jack off enough someone's
hijacked the plane so they've put the
plane back in air so season two is him
fighting off the hijackers oh you're
saying they turn it around yeah and then
I see yeah infinite fuel on this plane
right and then season three is like they
kill the hijackers and then he goes to
find this lady in premium economy
and he wants to like Kindle something
and then he discovers that her husband
also died 10 years ago and she only
recently discovered how to masturbate
again
and then the last at the the final shot
yeah
that's the final shot the final shot
the final shot
is she gives him a bit of encouragement
and she gets him back they're gonna say
a bit a bit of head no no okay this is
um this is a story of friendship oh yeah
okay this is a story of two people from
learning how to masturbate again yeah
learning how to you know and then the
final shot
is Idris backing up into the bathroom
and then they're both looking at each
other and she's like she's not she's
going into the one across the hallway no
she's standing outside of Idris okay
okay
this is a friend this is support no look
no no oh okay yeah no I thought it was I
thought it was supposed to be yes and
but that's fine no no no no it's cool
too no I learned this technique in
improv it's no no my way yeah yeah no
that sucks yeah how about this
well you can't look across the galley
it's blocked not in like a big ass plane
it's still blocked really yeah okay but
that I I like the thought
thanks I like the idea yeah thanks yeah
yeah but no
Idris is backing into the bathroom right
right
still hard as Nails yeah you're right
even hard for almost 24 hours this thing
is like gonna fall off right
and I bought the bus
and as he backs into the bathroom
he looks at her and he goes I'm about to
balls
and she goes to close the bathroom door
on him and they're just looking at each
other as the door is closing
and then he reaches
to grab her hand to stop her from
closing it okay
and then they look at each other and she
smiles and then it looks like she takes
a step forward to the camera and then
the end oh straight your credits hide
yeah yeah that's the post credits
a quick two seconds
and then just believe beneath it
you're like is that the airline toilet
flushing great or she giving him that
[__] suck the next
and then it's like yeah and then It
smash cut to like smash preview for next
season hi guck whoa
nice dude yep yeah no no no no no no no